The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I'm going to review
what we did with the craft
inequality just a little bit,
because evidently a number of
people were confused
about this.
I'm going to put a little more
notation in with it.
For some people,
notation helps.
For other people, it
hinders things.
But after you've thought about
it a little bit, a little more
notation can certainly
be helpful.
What we're trying to do in
this craft inequality is,
we're thinking of a set of
symbols where, supposing that
there's a codeword for each
symbol, c of x is the codeword
for symbol x, which is a string
of binary digits.
y1 up to y sub n.
In the world of two-toed sloths,
the representation of
numbers that sloths use
is binary, base 2.
And therefore, they use the
number associated with some
sequence of bits like this would
be the sum of y sub i,
times 2 to the minus i.
In other words, it's the same
thing as a decimal, except
it's in a world where
people have two
fingers instead of ten.
There's an interval associated
with this number, also.
And the interval is what you
would get if you took an
arbitrary real number and
rounded it down to l sub i.
Well, in this case to
m binary digits.
So that interval, then,
is the number itself.
And the other side of
the interval is that
number itself --
the two-toed sloth didn't like
what I was going to say about
it, and it changed my slide.
So, is that extra factor the
2 to the minus n, there.
In other words, any number in
that range, if you round it
down to m significant binary
digits is going to the this
number here.
Well the point of this, if the
number, namely, this base 2
expansion of a number y prime is
in this interval, then y is
going to be a prefix
of y prime.
Let me just give you some
examples of that because
saying it in words
is confusing, the
idea is very simple.
Suppose you have a binary
string, 011.
That corresponds to
the number 3/8.
Namely, 1/4 plus 1/8.
And the interval there is going
to be the interval from
3/8, including 3/8, up to 1/4.
But not including 1/4.
Namely, 1/4 will be represented
as -- the sloth
really is hitting hard
this morning.
Maybe I'm the sloth.
OK.
There we go.
From 3/8 to 1/2.
Namely, 1/2 is just 1.
Nothing more than that.
Or it could be 10 or
100, and so forth.
So then, as an example, 011 is
going to be a prefix of all of
these quantities here.
That's a prefix of 0111 because
0111 is 3/8 plus 1/16,
which is in that interval
we're talking about.
0110 is a more interesting
case.
Because 0110 is itself,
the number associated
with it, is just 3/8.
But what this is saying is, if
you take the same number but
expand it to four digits,
according to what this says, r
of y like is then in
this interval.
And therefore this prefix
situation holds.
So this is a prefix of this.
Why do I make it
so complicated?
I make it so complicated because
I want to talk about
the length of that interval.
And the length of these
intervals is denoted in this
diagram here.
Anytime I have a number
expressed to n binary digits,
it covers an interval
of 2 to the minus n.
And because of this prefix
property, as soon as one
number covers an interval, no
other number have its base in
that interval.
In other words, all of these
intervals have to be disjoint,
exactly as is indicated here.
So when you add up the size of
all these intervals, you have
to get something less
than or equal to 1.
And that's the proof of
the craft inequality.
So, let's go on and talk about
discrete source probabilities.
Now the two-toed sloth has
gotten his machine out there,
he's really mad at
me this morning.
If we try to model English
text, you know that some
letters are far more probable
than others.
Namely, if you take an enormous
amount of English
text and you measure the
relative frequency with which
each letter occurs, you'll get
more or less stable relative
frequencies if you
take enough text.
And these letters are far more
probable than these letters.
So that gives you
part of a model.
You can also say that successive
letters are going
to be very dependent.
Namely, t is very often followed
by h, and h is often
preceded by t.
q u is even more of a case
here, because as far as
English language words are
concerned, u always follows q.
Some letter strings are words.
Other letter strings
are not words.
There are constraints
on grammar.
And what is really the clincher,
which says there's
no way you're going to model
English in any sensible nice
way, is meaning.
And even worse than that,
depending on who writes the
English, it might have meaning
or it might not have meaning.
And for those English texts that
don't have any meaning,
the entropy is going to depend
very much on whether the
meaningless text is written by
a salesperson or it's written
by James Joyce.
And in one case you have --
well, in one case you have an
enormous amount of freedom in
what this sequence
of letters are.
And in the other case you have
letters which are very, very
constrained.
So what's the point of this?
The point of this is, if you're
interested in trying to
find the source coding method
for English, what you don't
want to do is to start out
trying to get the best
statistical model of English
that you can.
Because it's a losing
proposition.
And by trying to do that, you'll
spend all your time
trying to get the model.
And you won't get any insight
into what you ought to do as
far as source coding
is concerned.
This is pretty much true
throughout all of technology.
You don't solve problems by
first getting too far into the
details of what the problem is,
before you start thinking
about structures of possible
solutions.
In other words, we always deal
with technological problems by
dealing with toy
problems first.
Now, there's a difference
between engineers who worry
about toy problems.
Because engineers, if they hate
theory, usually, don't
say what the toy problem is.
But they have that toy problem
very firmly in the back of
their mind, because of
all their experience.
Theoreticians, on the other
hand, make their models very,
very explicit.
They don't often like to say
that they're toy models
because DARPA doesn't tend to
support things that are
working on toy models.
So they try to conceal this.
And often they just
hide the fact that
they're using a model.
So, all of this becomes
very complicated.
But, for you, if you're trying
to do either engineering or
mathematics or teaching, or
just be a sensible person.
When you're dealing with these
problems, be explicit about
what your models are.
Try to understand the toy
problems before you understand
the more complicated problems.
If you understand that out of
this course, it'll be a
worthwhile course for you.
And, of course, you won't
understand it until you get
lots more experience.
But believe me, that's
the way it is.
OK, so that's the whole
point of this.
You want to start with
simple toy models.
And I'm not just justifying the
fact that we're going to
study this incredibly
simple model here,
which is a toy model.
But by studying this
you will see that
everything else follows.
If you read Claude Shannon's
work on information theory,
this, in fact, is where
he started.
He started with a beautiful
description of trying to model
the English language.
Finally wound up with
talking about this.
The conclusions he drew, from
studying these discrete memory
sources, lead to his general
theorems about data
compression on sources.
They led to his general
theorems about
the capacity of channels.
They led to the idea that you
want to separate source coding
from channel coding, and
finally, they led to all of
the modern ideas that we have
about quantization.
In other words, the simple
ideas you get out of this
generalize directly to
everything that's known about
information theory.
So.
Enough philosophy, let's get on
with the business of what
we're trying to do.
A discrete memoryless sources
has the following properties.
The source output has to be an
unending sequence, x1, x2, x3,
blah, blah, blah, of random
letters drawn from a finite
alphabet, x.
In other words, we are taking
these real sources.
And we're saying, let's make
them not real now.
Let's put a probability
measure on them.
And in this probability measure,
one of the things
that the probability measure
will do will be to describe
the probability on each one of
these letters and the sequence
in which it's coming
out of the source.
Each source output, x1, x2,
blah, blah, blah, is selected
from a common alphabet.
Namely, if you're using English
on one letter of the
sequence, you're going to
use English on every
letter of the sequence.
Going to use a common
probability measure, with some
probability mass function
p sub x of x.
This notation means this is the
probability mass function
for the chance variable X. A
chance variable is like a
random variable, except
the objects are
not necessarily numbers.
The objects can be anything.
So, a chance variable is a
generalization of a random variable.
So this probability mass
function talks about the
probability of each of the
symbols in this alphabet x.
Then the final thing is, each
source output, x sub k, is
statistically independent of all
other source outputs, x1
up x k minus 1, and x k
plus 1 on to forever.
This is a nice example, because
if you're going to
specify a source
probabilistically, you have to
somehow find a way of
explaining what the
probability of every possible
event within this source is.
This is an easy way
of doing it.
You say they're independent.
And then you can find the
probability of anything you
want to find.
So that's a generic
way of putting
probability measures on things.
So then, we want to go into the
idea of prefix-free codes
for these discrete memory
of the sources.
We've already talked about
prefix-free codes.
We talked about the
craft inequality.
You might have thought it was
a little bit strange talking
about the strictly combinatorial
property of
codes without talking at all
about the probabilities, which
are the things that led us into
talking about these codes
in the first place.
Namely, we want to use unequal
length, variable length codes.
Because of the fact that some
letters are more likely than
other letters.
And eventually we'll be using
them because of all these
constraints between
different words.
So, for notation, let l of x be
the length of the codeword
for letter x in, the alphabet
capital X. ok so that's the
same as this y1 y2
up to y sub n.
At some strength of
binary symbols.
Capital L of x is a random
variable, where capital L of x
is equal to little l of x, where
capital X equal to x.
Now, what the heck
does that mean?
It's just notation.
In other words, what we're
starting out with is this
ensemble of letters.
We have a probability assignment
on each letter in
that alphabet.
And then what we would like
to talk about is a length
function on those letters.
So we have little l of x, which
is defined for each x.
We then want to talk about this
as a random variable.
Because when we choose some
random letter, x, little x, of
this ensemble, capital X, l of
x becomes a random variable.
We will always, in this course,
use capital letters to
talk about random variables.
And we will always use little
letters to talk about things
which are not random
variables.
Excuse me, not not random
variables but random variables
or chance variables.
I think we can probably
leave it open now.
It seems as if the sloth
has gone away.
So then we want to talk
about the expected
value of the length.
You talk about the expected
value of something, you're
talking about the expected value
of a random variable.
We will also denote the expected
value of this random
variable L with a bar over it,
which is the sum over the
letters in the alphabet,
of p of x times L of x.
So all this is what you would do
anyway if you never thought
about this.
Until, at some point, when
you're taking a quiz or
something and start to get
confused and say, what is this
stuff all about?
I don't have any idea what
this means after you've
written five pages of stuff.
So, it's worthwhile spending
a little bit of time
sorting that out.
So, L bar is the number
of encoder output
bits per source symbol.
In some strange sense.
Namely, it's this
expected value.
Now, to finish this off, if we
want to look at the number of
binary digits to come out of
the source when a long
sequence of letters come
out of the source --
A long sequence of letters. x1,
x2, x3, and so forth, come
out of the source.
They go into the encoder.
The encoder is mapping each
letter that comes out of the
source into this codeword
c of x.
So we have a sequence of
codewords which are all
concatenated together.
And, therefore, the total number
of binary digits which
has come out of the source
corresponding to these n
symbols that have come out of
the source, is the sum of L of
x1 plus L of x2 plus of x3 plus
L of x4, and so forth.
So we have a sum of independent
random variables.
Now, what do you know
about sums of
independent random variables?
Well, the one thing you ought
to know about, and which
should be stamped on your brain
because it's the central
thing that makes any
probabilistic theory make
sense, it's the only way that
we can ever understand our
environment.
You look at the past.
You try to figure out
from the past what's
going on in the future.
And the only way you can do
that, the only tool you have,
really, is this law
of large, numbers.
Which says, when you see a long
sequence of things, from
that long sequence of things,
you sort of figure out
what's going on.
If you're dealing with a random
variable, the thing you
do is add up all of
these numbers.
You divide by the total number
of them that you have.
And that gives you the
expected value.
It gives you a typical value.
What the law of large numbers
really says is, if you look at
the sum of binary digits out of
this encoder, over a very
long period of time, divide by
the total number of symbols,
that's a random variable
again.
And this random variable is,
with high probability, going
to be very, very close to this
expected value, which is this
quantity here.
In other words, the ensemble
average, which is this, is
going to be very close
to the time average.
And the time average, now,
is a random variable.
And that's what the law
of large numbers says.
You see, the problem that we
all have, dealing with real
world problems, is that there's
nobody to tell us this
is what the ensemble is.
Unless you believe somebody
that doesn't know.
And the only real evidence
that you have
is the actual sequence.
And from the actual sequence,
you then look at what happens
for this particular sequence.
You then build a model.
And your model, by definition,
has the expected value of L
going to be equal to the
expected value in the model
that you've chosen.
So.
What's your objective?
Your objective in trying to form
a prefix-free code, then,
is to find a set of integers,
L of x, which satisfy the
Kraft inequality.
And they minimize L bar.
In other words, what we're
trying to do is, we're trying
to choose a code which minimizes
the expected length
of the code.
Which is really, over a long
period of time, going to
minimize the number of binary
digits that come out of the
source encoder.
What we want to do is to choose
these integers to
minimize this.
So what we're going to do now
is, suppose our alphabet is
just 1, 2, up to capital N.
What am I doing here?
I'm saying, we don't care about
what these symbols are
called, anyway.
It's totally irrelevant what the
names of the symbols are.
So I will name them 1, 2, up to
capital N. Probability mass
function, then, I can denote as
p sub 1 up to p sub capital
N. In other words I've gotten
rid of all these axes that
were lousing up our equations
all along.
Now, I'll denote the unknown
lengths by l1 up to l sub M.
So the problem is, somebody
gives you this set of numbers.
p1 to p sub M, which is a PMF.
In other words, these
numbers add up to 1.
And tells you, I want a
prefix-free code which
minimizes this expected
length.
Namely, the expected value
corresponding to
these lengths here.
So, the expected length, to
minimize it, what we want to
do is to minimize over the
choice of l1 up to l sub M.
Subject to the craft inequality,
we want to
minimize this expected value.
So we have a nice, clean,
mathematical problem now.
We want to minimize this sum,
subject to this constraint.
And the constraint includes
the fact that all of these
things have to be integers.
Well, for those of you who have
studied minimization,
there's a funny thing in here.
Because integer minimization
problems tend to
be very, very nasty.
And, therefore, you look at
this and you say, this is
probably something I'm going
to have trouble solving.
Strangely enough, it isn't.
But you would think it probably
is something which
will be hard to solve.
So, since integers louse
up minimization
problems, what do we do?
Well, we say, just for fun
let's try to solve this
problem without the integer
constraint on it.
Let's see what that leads
to, and see if we can do
anything with that.
So we say, OK, let's try to
minimize this function here
over the integers l1 to l sub M,
subject to this constraint.
So we're minimizing this,
Now, an easy way to
do that -- yes.
AUDIENCE: Are you
saying that side length is
not a fixed probability.
PROFESSOR: No, I still have
these fixed probabilities.
I still have p1 up to p sub
M, as known probabilities.
But I'm going to say, let's
suppose I can choose a length
which is two point five bits
instead of two bits.
AUDIENCE: You're saying
the shortest length
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, we're going to
wind up there eventually.
But for now, all I want to do
is to look at this problem.
If I start out by saying, assign
shortest lengths to the
biggest probabilities,
I have two problems.
One is, it's a little hard
to prove to you that
I want to do that.
Although we'll do that
later today.
And the other is, it doesn't
really give you the general
properties that we want
to know about this.
So, for those two reasons, I
want to just attack this as a
straightforward mathematical
problem.
If you're a computer scientist,
this looks strange.
Because computer scientists
like to attack problems by
algorithms.
Analog engineers like to attack
problems by writing a
complicated formula, and taking
derivatives, and all
sorts of things like that.
We're going to be doing
both of those
things in this course.
And you'll see that both
of them lead to certain
advantages.
And here, we're taking, where
the analog engineer's approach
is saying, suppose this
is a bunch of numbers.
I want to minimize this
function over a set of
numbers, l1 up to
l sub capital M.
So, how do I do that?
Well, this guy Lagrange, he
was a great mathematician.
He was also a great
mathematician early enough
that he could do some really
trivial things and become
famous for them.
Just like Kraft that we were
talking about before.
But, unlike Kraft, Lagrange
really did a lot of other very
important things.
And what Lagrange said was the
following: Well, suppose I
want to minimize this sum.
And I want to have this
constraint added in.
Sort of what I want to do,
then, is to minimize a
weighted sum of this,
which is what I'm
interested in, and this.
In other words, if I minimize
this weighted sum here of
these two things, I'm going to
wind up with some sort of
value for this.
And some sort of
By changing lambda, then, which
stands for Lagrange, he
was also clever in making
himself famous that way, by
changing lambda, I can change
the balance between how
important these two
things are.
And as I change the balance
between how important they
are, when I change it to just
the right place, I'm going to
have this constraint here
satisfied with equality.
So that's the whole idea of
Lagrange minimization.
So we take this function.
How do you now minimize a
function of multiple variables?
Well, again it's a
messy problem.
But the first thing you
can try to do is find
a stationary point.
So, let's always do the
easy thing first.
We take the partial derivative
of this function here, with
respect to l sub i.
That's what we're trying
to minimize.
And what we get is p sub i minus
lambda times the natural
log of 2, times 2 the
minus l sub i.
I'm not very good at
differentiation any more, so I
only differentiate things
which are easy.
And that's easy.
I want to find a stationary
point, so I set
this equal to 0.
That makes the problem worse,
because now I have a function
of lambda and also all
of these l sub i's.
But now I choose l sub i, so
that I satisfy the constraint.
Namely, I choose lambda to
satisfy this equation here.
When I choose lambda to satisfy
this equation here,
what I get is p sub i is equal
to 2 to the minus l i, and
therefore, l sub i is equal
to minus log p sub i.
In other words, I have
this equation here.
What happens when I sum
this equation over i?
Let's look at it.
We sum this over i.
The sum of p i over i is 1 minus
lambda times natural log
of 2 times sum of 2 to
the minus l sub i.
And I want to make
this equal to 1.
So what I get is 1 is equal
to this times lambda
natural log of 2.
So, I hope that choosing lambda
equal to 1 over natural
log of 2 is what I want to do.
And when I do that, this
becomes 1 here.
And I just have 2 to the minus
lambda i is equal to 1.
OK, good.
And then, going back to this
equation, p sub i is equal to
2 to the minus l sub i.
OK, this is this arithmetic.
I mean, if you don't follow what
I'm doing, just look at
it later and you'll find that
there's nothing really there.
So we wind up with these lengths
being equal to the
negative of the binary
logarithms of these
probabilities.
It's only a stationary point.
We don't know whether
it's a minimum yet.
And, unfortunately, we also
have the problem of, they
might not be integers.
But, anyway, what we wind up
with, then, if we ignore
looking at these problems for
the time being, is that the
lengths are going to
be equal to this.
The expected value of the
lengths is then going to be
equal to the sum, over i, of
minus p sub i times the
logarithm of p sub i.
When Shannon saw this, and when
various other people saw
it, they said, gee, this looks
like the entropy of
statistical mechanics.
So let's call this
quantity entropy.
For no better reason
than that.
And it would probably have been
far better if they called
it something else.
Because for years, there were
physicists and philosophers
trying to figure out what the
deep relationship was between
statistical mechanical
entropy and
information theoretic entropy.
And there probably is such
a relationship, but the
relationship is far more
complicated than understanding
information theory.
And it's far more
complicated than
understanding statistical mechanics.
So I advise you to not worry
about that one until after you
understand what it means in an
information theoretic sense.
So h of x is what we call
the entropy of the
random variable x.
And it really is the entropy
associated with these
logarithms of p sub i.
So when you take functions of
a random variable, a random
variable carries along a
lot of baggage with it.
Including the probabilities
of everything.
And when you take the expected
value of a random variable,
the individual values of the
sample points of that random
variable are important.
And the probabilities
are important.
Here we have something
even stranger.
Because it's only the
probabilities that have
anything to do with it.
And this makes sense.
We already said that these
symbols have nothing to do
with this problem we're
dealing with.
You can call the symbols
whatever you
want to call them.
And, therefore, the only thing
of any interest to us is these
probabilities that we're
dealing with.
So H of x is a function only
of these probabilities.
It's the expected value
of minus log p sub i.
This is called entropy, and in
fact we will find out very
shortly that it really is the
minimum number of bits per
source symbol needed to
represent the source.
In other words, when we
generalize the problem from
just plain ordinary
garden-variety oh prefix-free
codes, we will find that this
number is really what
characterizes the whole
problem for discrete
memory-less sources.
So let's go on and say
more about that.
Let's say something about
bounds on the entropy.
First, what's the relationship
between the entropy and this
minimum of the expected length
that we started to talk about?
And I claim that H of x is less
than or equal to L min,
which is less than the
entropy plus 1.
And why is that?
We already have the machinery
to see this.
We almost have the machinery
Namely, we have solved this
minimization problem.
We've only found a stationary
point, but we've ignored the
fact that we have an
integer constraint.
So, if you allow me to say for
the time being that, in fact,
when we solve the problem
without worrying about
integers, that it actually gives
me a minimum, then in
fact this follows very easily.
Because what I'm going to do
is to find those optimal
lengths, which are
non-integers.
And then I can solve the prefix
condition and get a
code by simply increasing each
of those numbers to the next
integer up.
In other words, I can take the
ceiling function of each of
those real numbers to
get an integer.
When I take the ceiling
function, 2 to the minus l sub
i is going to go down.
So the craft inequality
is still satisfied.
So the entropy has to be less
than or equal to this average.
Has to be less than
H of x plus 1.
So the average is equal to H of
x if and only if each these
probabilities it an integer
power of 2 to start with.
In other words, the solution I
came up with before is that
the length I wanted should be
equal to minus the logarithm
to base 2, of p sub i.
So if p sub i is already a power
of 2 then I'm home free.
Because I just pick that length
to be minus log of p
sub i, and it happens
to be an integer.
And I don't have
to round it up.
So if I let l1 to lM be these
codeword lengths -- well,
here's where I'm going
to prove this to you.
And the proof is the following:
I want to prove
that H of x is less than or
equal to l min, which I'll
just call here L bar.
So H of x minus L bar is equal
to, this is the entropy.
This is the expected
length here.
I can rewrite this as the sum of
p sub i times logarithm of
2 to the minus l sub i
divided by p sub i.
That's just arithmetic.
l sub i is equal to to logarithm
of 2 to the l sub i,
that's equal to minus
the logarithm of 2
the minus l sub i.
So I get this.
There's an inequality.
Hate to call it an inequality,
it's so trivial.
Here's the point 1.
If you plot a natural
log of x.
And if you compare it with the
function x minus 1, you can
see that natural log of
x is less than or
equal to x minus 1.
Now, this an inequality which
happens to be very useful in
information theory.
I would claim that any
inequality that you can prove
in information theory, by any
means at all, I can prove
using this inequality
and nothing else.
And I've believed that for
50 years and nobody's
proven me wrong yet.
And also, this is something
you can draw and remember.
So it's simple.
So the idea, then, is since this
sum log of 2 to the minus
l over p sub i is less than or
equal to the natural log of 2
times the natural logarithm
of this.
You just, here we go.
For any u greater than 0,
natural log of u is less than
or equal to this.
So the logarithm to the base 2
of u is less than or equal to
the logarithm to the base 2 of
e, which is some number,
times u minus 1.
With equality at u equals 1.
So this is less than
or equal to this.
And look how nice that is.
The p sub i's cancel out and you
get the sum over i, of 2
the minus l i minus p sub i is
less than or equal to 0.
An equality occurs if, and only
if, p sub i is equal to 2
to the minus l i.
OK?
So that's all there is to it.
And that establishes that --
well, establishes part of this
theorem here.
And the other part we already
established, And if you don't
believe me, the notes do
it more carefully.
Well, this left us a serious
problem unknown.
Which is, how do you actually
solve this integer
minimization problem.
How do you solve it if you have
a big, long, complicated
source with lots of
probabilities in it?
And everybody thought
it was hopeless.
Even Shannon thought
And Shannon sort of figured
out ways to
approach this problem.
He said, well, you want
to have about half the
probability.
Starting with 1, about
half the probability
starting with 0.
So he would divide up the
symbols in the alphabet, so he
could come as close is possible
to half of them being
up here and half of them
coming down here.
And he would continue to do
that, I mean, I don't usually
like to write on the blackboard,
but he would start
out generating a
code like this.
And this would be approximately
1/2.
This is approximately 1/2.
And then he would take
these symbols.
Split them, again,
in probability.
And everybody was starting the
problem over here, and trying
to generate a code working
their way out.
Well, Dave Huffman was a
graduate student at the time.
and he took Bob Fano's graduate
course in information
theory, I think a year or
so later than Kraft did.
And Bob Fano assigned as a
homework problem, how do you
solve this problem?
Sneaky guy.
And he was very amazed when Dave
Hoffman came in next day
and said, oh, it's easy,
you do it this way.
So the question is,
how did he do it?
Well, Huffman, instead of
looking at the problem from
here out, looked at the
problem from here in.
He was --
I mean, this was before
there was anything
called computer science.
But he thought like a computer
scientist did.
In other words, he thought
algorithmically.
And he also thought in terms
of discrete problems.
And therefore, he looked for
properties that these optimum
codes should have.
And it was neat.
So, he started out
with a limit.
He said, an optimal code has to
have the property that a p
i is greater than p sub j.
Then the optimal length
associated with p sub i,
namely the optimal length of the
i'th codeword, had to be
less than or equal to the length
of the j'th codeword.
And you can see this
by saying, well,
suppose that's not true.
Suppose that p i is
greater than p j.
And also, li is greater
than lj.
And then you say, OK,
take this situation.
We will interchange those two
codewords in the code.
And we'll look at what that
does to the average.
And if you work that through,
you find out that since what
you've done is, you've shortened
the codeword
associated with this and
lengthened the codeword
associated with this.
You have changed the average
length to make it smaller.
Now, let me warn you
about something.
When you start looking at these
properties, the most
confusing thing is what happens
when two probabilities
are the same, or when two
lengths are the same.
And I would advise you to just
ignore that problem, until you
get an idea of what's
going on.
Namely, assume that all
lengths are different.
All probabilities
are different.
And then it's easy to
see what's going on.
And when you get all done, go
back and straighten out the
cases where things are equal.
And I think the notes
do this carefully.
If you read books on information
theory, about half
of them do it carefully, and
about half of them don't.
So you should be suspicious.
But anyway, that's one of those
trivialities that you
just have to sort out
for yourself.
OK.
The next lemma is optimal
prefix-free codes are full.
We talked about what
a full code is.
When you draw this binary graph
for it, you don't have
any nodes in a binary graph --
you don't have any leaves
that are not
associated with codewords.
Because if you do, we showed
you that shortened the
codeword of the part of
the tree on the other
side of that leaf.
In other words, if you have
something here, if this is a
codeword and this is not a
codeword, then you just get
rid of this, and bring
that back here.
But this is a whole tree
stemming off here, you do the
same thing.
You take this whole tree and you
bring it into there, and
you throw this away.
So, optimal prefix-free
codes are full.
So far there's nothing
to this.
The next part of it is the
sibling of a codeword.
And what's a sibling?
Well, we used to call
it a brother.
But then couldn't do that
because we have to call it a
brother or sister.
And that got to difficult.
So people invented the word
sibling, to talk about a
brother or a sister.
So the sibling of a codeword
for is the string form by
changing the last bit.
In other words, in this
family tree here, the
sibling of this is this.
The sibling of this is this.
So, a leaf can have a sibling
which is an intermediate node,
and vice versa.
So then he said, the sibling
of a codeword is a string
formed by changing
the last bit.
I think he probably said the
brother, but, anyway.
For optimality, the sibling of
each maximum length codeword
is another codeword.
Now, that's a really
simple one.
If I make this a codeword, and
this is the maximal length
codeword in this code I'm
talking about, this can't be
an intermediate node because
then there would have to be
longer codewords.
And it can't be empty because
these optimal
codes are all full.
And therefore, this has
to have a sibling
which is also a codeword.
So the longest codewords
have to have siblings.
Well, that's easy enough.
Incidentally, one of the
problems that you have in
proving this sort of thing is,
what happens if you have
zero-probability letters.
Well, we just get rid of that
problem and say, well, there
aren't any zero-probability
letters.
Because if we want to come up
with a sensible model for
something, we're not going
to create a codeword for
something that can't happen.
So, there are no
zero-probability letters in
this alphabet.
I mean, if you want to put them
in, it just complicates
the whole thing.
And you can do it.
Then, finally, there's this
lemma which says, there is an
optimal prefix-free code in
which, after you order the
probabilities of all of the
messages, namely you order p1
to be greater than or equal
to p2, greater than or
equal to p sub m.
In other words, we just rename
the letters in the alphabet,
so that letter m is less likely
than letter m minus 1,
and so forth.
Back to 1.
1 is the most probable,
m is the least likely.
Well, we've already concluded
that we want to assign the
longest messages to the least
probable codewords.
And this says, take the two
least probable codewords and
we can always make an optimal
code in which those two
codewords are siblings.
And the reason for that is, one
of them is not going to be
longer than the other or else
you can shorten the code by
interchanging things.
So there is an optimal
prefix-free code in which the
codeword for m minus 1.
And the codeword for
m are maximal
length and they're siblings.
So the Huffman algorithm first
combines these two.
And then looks at the reduced
tree with m minus 1 nodes.
Let me show you an
example of that.
So it starts out.
Here, I've ordered the
probabilities associated with
a set of symbols.
The symbols are 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
The two least likely messages
are 0.1 and 0.15.
Obviously, I could've
interchanged these
two if I want to.
But why interchange them?
So I say, OK, the last digit
on this one, I'm going to
assign to be a 0.
The last digit on this, I'm
going to assign to be a 1.
And the important thing is,
I'm going to make them
siblings in this tree.
And what I'm going to do now,
terribly complicated thing,
instead of building a tree from
left to right, I'm going
to build a tree from
right to left.
So when I get all done with
the tree it's going to
come in like this.
And what I'm doing is starting
out at the end, to start to
build the end of the tree.
And what happens after I go
through this first step is, I
say, OK there is an
optimal code.
In which these two
quantities are
siblings of maximal length.
I now want to form an optimal
code for these
probabilities here.
So, I go back and
I iterate again.
And I said, OK, if I have these
probabilities here,
what's the optimal code.
Well, I could reorder
the things.
But now I know that the only
thing I'm interested in is the
two least likely symbols in
this new alphabet here.
Which is 0.2 and 0.15.
So I combine those together.
I tie them together as
siblings in this last
generation, however
it works out.
So then I have an alphabet
of size three.
And then down here,
I have these
two things tied together.
These two things
tied together.
So I have a node of
probability 0.25.
I have a node of probability
0.35, and I have a node of
probability 0.4.
I take the two least likely,
and I tie them together.
And then I have two nodes left,
one with probability 0.6
and one with probability 0.4.
And I tie them together.
And, presto, I have my whole
code, except for flipping it
over, to go from left to
right if you like.
Codes that go from
left and right,
instead of right to left.
OK.
I have swindled you.
How have I swindled you?
I mean, I've swindled you a
little bit by talking about
these things that might
be equal or not equal.
And that's not important.
You can sort that
out on your own.
There's a very important
swindle I pulled.
And what's that?
What's very incomplete
in this argument?
This part is fine.
Nothing wrong here.
We have a lemma which says, you
can find an optimal code
by tying these two
things together.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
combine those two
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] combination.
PROFESSOR: You're saying,
how do I know to
combine these two?
OK, which means what?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you've just added the
probabilities --
PROFESSOR: I've just added
those two probabilities.
So I have a new ensemble where
I have four probabilities,
0.25, 0.15, 0.2, and 0.4.
And that's fine.
I still have these things.
No, there's no independence
involved here at all.
I mean, I started out
with five letters.
Which are disjoined.
I now have four letters
that are disjoined.
What have I done?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yeah.
I have assumed, now, that once I
get these four symbols, if I
have those four symbols, I can
form an optimal code for those
four symbols in which these two
symbols get tied together.
But how do I know that an
optimal code for this reduced
set of probabilities is also
an optimal code for the
original problem?
I have tied these two
things together.
I know there's an optimal code
in which these two things are
tied together.
I then have four symbols.
I want to find a code for
those four symbols.
But I assume that the optimal
code for these four symbols,
when I break apart these two
things, gives me an optimal
code for five symbols.
That's the sort of thing I
want you people to start
catching onto immediately.
I want you to start asking
those nasty questions.
And those nasty questions are
the things that say, OK, how
do I know that this works?
In other words, you're not
here to learn these
algorithms.
I can tell you what the
algorithm is in an instant.
You can do the algorithm.
A computer can do the algorithm
about three thousand
times faster than you can.
And you can be replaced by a
computer, if you only learn
the algorithms.
You can program the algorithm.
You can probably find the
computer that can program the
algorithm too.
And there's no need to program
it more than once.
So that after you've done that,
you are useless again.
So the only thing that's
worthwhile for you is to be
able to spot these problems
and to understand
what's going on.
So.
How do I know that this first
optimization leads to the
second optimization.
After combining these two least
likely codewords, or
siblings, we've gotten a reduced
set of probabilities.
In this problem here, what we've
done, the reduced set of
probabilities are 0.4,
0.2, 0.15, and 0.25.
Why does finding the optimal
code for this reduced set
result in an optimal code
for the original set?
That's really the question
that we're asking.
Well, it's not hard.
If you take any code for the
reduced set, let's call the
reduced set x prime, set
of probabilities.
Let the expected length
of that be l prime.
It's not necessarily an optimal
code, but it's any old
code that I generate.
Any old code I generate for L
prime, I can now take that
code for l prime and I can
expand it out to a code for L.
Namely, I have this code here
this, this, this, and that's
the expanded --
and now I can expand it into a
code for the original set, by
adding on this and this,
as leaves on this.
This leaf here then becomes
an intermediate node.
And I add two extra
leaves to it.
OK, well, it's not hard.
The expected length for this
code, for these five letters,
I claim, is equal to the
expected length for this
reduced code, this, this,
this, and this.
Plus one extra digit for this.
So the expected length for L is
the expected length for L
prime plus 0.15 plus 0.1.
Which says the following: if I
want to minimize this, and I
know that this has to be equal
to this, and these two numbers
are fixed, I can't
change them.
I can minimize this,
by minimizing this.
And that's the final step
in the whole argument.
And what's peculiar
is that everybody
learns the Huffman algorithm.
And what Huffman did, which was
really very smart, was to
sort out this issue.
And I can teach this to a
hundred classes, and nobody
will ever point out to me that
there's a logical flaw in the
whole argument.
And you can look at most books
on information theory and they
never point out that
there's that
logical flaw there, either.
So, anyway, that's the end
of Huffman's algorithm.
You can see when you look at
this that this is really an
extraordinarily easy
thing to do.
I mean, you can take
an alphabet of
several thousand symbols.
All you have to do
is order them.
Tie the least two
likely together.
Assign a 1 and a 0 to them.
Then, stick that into an
ordered list again.
Take the two least probable.
Tie them together.
Stick it into an ordered
list again.
And, if you have some minimal
knowledge of data structures,
you can do this with essentially
on the order of
one operation for each letter
in this alphabet.
So it really isn't a
very difficult sum.
So here's an integer problem
which is really easy to solve.
And the way to solve it is to
look at the problem in the
opposite way from what
everybody else has
looked at it in.
Does this say you want to
ignore everything that
everybody else has done,
and go your own way?
Not quite.
But it says that's one of the
things you ought to try, if
you find that everybody is doing
something one way and
you can find another way to
look at, that's very rich.
It might turn out to be nothing
but it might turn out
to be something very
worthwhile.
Let's now talk about this
quantity, entropy.
And for every chance variable,
x, if that chance variable, x,
is discrete and has a finite
number of elements in it, so
I'm talking about a chance
variable x, what's a chance
variable have tagging
along after it?
It has a set of n probabilities
tagging along after it.
That's what a chance
variable is.
A chance variable is not
just the alphabet.
A chance variable is the
alphabet plus the
probabilities.
That's why you then talk about
it having an entropy.
And the entropy is the expected
value of, minus the
logarithm, of this
PMF function.
So, in fact, this is an unusual
statistic in the sense
that it has nothing to do with
the symbol values, and
everything to do with just
the probabilities
of the symbol values.
And as we go on, you'll see that
in fact this is a very
important property of it.
And dealing with the logarithms
of these symbol
values is, in fact, a much more
worthwhile thing to do
than dealing with the
probabilities of the symbols.
Now, let me pause again and see
if anybody can have any
idea of why logarithms of
probabilities might be more
significant than
probabilities.
And think of what we're going
to be doing here.
We're taking a sequence
of letters.
When I take a sequence of
letters, what's the
probability of the sequence
of letters?
If they're IID.
Namely, we're looking --
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's the product
of those probabilities.
Now, if you agree with me that
the probability theory is
concerned 50% with the law of
large numbers and 50% with
everything else all put
together, why is the logarithm
of a probability important?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You change your
product to a sum, yes.
If you have a product of
probabilities, you can talk
about a sum of the logarithms
of probabilities.
That's why entropy is important
in statistical mechanics.
It also is, fundamentally,
the reason why entropy is
important in information
theory.
Is because what you're almost
always interested in is a
product of probabilities.
And when you're interested in a
product of probabilities and
you want to use the law of large
numbers, you turn that
product of probabilities into
a sum of the logarithms of
probabilities.
Fundamental idea.
Shannon took eight years
sorting all this out.
And Shannon was by far the
smartest person I've ever met.
I mean, the problems that we
worry about, he just, bip.
Solves it with no
effort at all.
This one took them a
while to sort out.
It also took him a while to sort
out the fact that once he
sorted this out, he could sort
out all of the other problems.
As far as communications
was concerned.
So was quite important.
I mean, I can tell you
one of the peculiar
things about Shannon.
Just from the first time I ever
talked to him about a
technical problem.
I'd just become a faculty
member here.
And his office was about five
doors down from mine.
And one day I screwed up my
courage to go down and talk to
the guy about a problem
I was working on.
And I thought it was a
really neat problem.
It had all sorts of pieces to
it, all sorts of bells and
whistles on it.
And I started to explain
it to him.
And he said, well, can we look
at a slightly simpler case
where you throw out this part of
it, you throw out one bell.
Then he'd throw out a whistle.
Then he'd throw out a bell.
And I was going along with
this and saying,
yeah, I guess we could.
We could.
We can throw out all of these
things without really losing
the essence of the problem.
And, finally, I started
to get discouraged.
Because this really neat
research problem, this really
important research problem,
was turning a toy problem
which was almost trivial.
It had nothing to do, it
seemed, with anything.
And finally we got down
to a certain point.
And I said, yeah, but this is
trivial, the solution is this.
And he said, yeah.
And then we started putting
back all the pieces.
And his genius was, he knew
which things to throw out.
So that each of the things we
threw out, we could put them
back in again.
When we got done, the research
problem was trivial.
And his genius was in finding
the right trivial
example to look at.
So, in fact, what you always
want to look at, in the
communications field -- and in
most fields, I think -- is
finding the really simple way
of looking at something.
Which means you have to throw
out most of the nonsense.
So, in this case, it's looking
at entropy, which is the
logarithm of a probability
assignment.
And you want to look at that
because the logarithm of a
probability assignment lets
you add the logarithms of
probabilities.
Use the law of large numbers.
And then you can talk about
sequences of elements.
Properties of entropy.
For a discrete random
chance variable.
We have m elements
in the alphabet.
First thing is that the entropy
is always greater than
or equal to 0.
Why is that?
I'll let you figure it out.
Why is the logarithm of a
problem, minus the logarithm
of a probability, greater
than or equal to 0?
Why is it non-negative?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Probabilities
are always less than
or equal to 1, yes.
So this quantity here
is always greater
than or equal to 0.
Because the logarithm
of 1 is equal to 0.
We have a quality here if
x is deterministic.
Which is just a special
case there.
Where you have an ensemble
of one element and it has
probability 1.
Or, in fact, at this point you
could add in things which have
zero probability.
Well, that's a little
bit tricky.
Because you add in something
that's zero probability.
And the logarithm of
0 is infinity.
So you're dealing with the
expected value of a bunch of
infinities, which each occur
with zero probability.
And you're forced to say, well,
I think that 0 times log
of 0 is equal to 0.
And in fact, epsilon times log
of episilon goes to 0 as
epsilon goes to 0.
But you save yourself a lot of
worry by just leaving out
things of zero probability.
So H of x is greater
than or equal to 0.
We have equality if x
is deterministic.
H of x is less than or
equal to log of m.
The quality, if x
is equiprobable.
And how do I know that?
I look at this again.
I'm not going to prove it here
but, essentially, this follows
from saying that the natural
logarithm of something is less
than or equal to that
something minus 1.
And you take the difference of
the entropy, and log of m.
And, presto, it gives you the
result that you want.
So you've got the most entropy,
if everything is
equiprobable.
For any code satisfying the
Kraft inequality, the entropy
is less than or equal
to L bar.
Well, that's what we
already proved.
Mainly in the middle of the
lecture, we showed that for
any code to satisfied the Kraft
inequality, the entropy
was always less than or equal to
L bar, because the entropy
is what you get if you minimize
the expected length
without the integer
constraint.
And L bar is what you get --
well, L bar min is what you
get when you minimize it with
the integer constraint.
I mean, you don't bother
about minimizing it.
You get something bigger
than L min.
So this is less than or equal to
the length of any codeword.
For the very best codeword, for
the very best code, the
expected value of the minimum
is less than or equal to the
entropy plus y.
And you get that just by adding
to each non-integer
length the ceiling function.
Which gives you, at most, one
extra digit for each codeword.
Now, here's the more
interesting one.
For independent chance
variables, x and y, here's
where the nice part about
notation comes along.
What's the entropy of x y?
Well, what do I mean
by x y first?
I have a chance variable, x.
And this chance variable x has
an alphabet associated with
it. x1 up to x sub m.
I have a chance variable y.
It has an alphabet associated
with it.
What's the sample space, what's
the set of events
corresponding to the chance
variable x y?
By x y, I mean a chance variable
whose elements are
the possible values
of both x and y.
So, I'm talking about the joint
ensemble of x and y.
I have a bunch of possible
values for that.
And those possible values, if
I have m possibilities for
each, I have m squared
possible values
for the two of them.
So I'm talking about the
expected value of minus the
logarithm of the probability
of x and y.
In other words, I am trying
to take the --
let me write it out.
I'm probably given conniptions
to -- no?
OK.
I want to take p of x y of
symbol x y, times minus the
logarithm to the base 2
of p sub x y of x y.
That's what this means
if I write it out.
Well, this probability here is
p sub x of little x, times p
sub y of little y.
Why is that?
Because I'm assuming
that they're
independent of each other.
And, therefore, the probability
of two of them is
the product of the
probabilities, times minus log
to the base 2.
So if p sub x of x minus
logarithm to the base 2 of p
sub y of y.
And I'm summing this over
all x and all y.
And the more sophisticated
way to write this --
things I say in lecture, you
don't have to copy down
because they're always
in the notes.
If they're not in the
notes, it's probably
wrong anyway, so.
So this expected value is
expected value of the
logarithm of the probability
of x y.
Which is the expected value
of the logarithm of p of
x times p of y.
And, since I have a logarithm
of a product, that's the
expected value of minus log p
of x minus log p of y, which
is the entropy of x plus
the entropy of y.
In other words, when I have a
joint ensemble of even more
independent quantities, The
entropy the sequence is equal
to the sum of the entropies of
the individual elements in
that sequence.
Well, that's all I wanted
to talk about today.
If any of you have any questions
to ask, you should
ask them now.
I went through Huffman coding
pretty quickly, because it's
something where you have
to do some exercises on
it to sort it out.
And I didn't want to do
any more than that.